alle leute ist wieder eure um eine wanne
und wir kommen wieder heute cookies das
war anstrengender als gedacht ich mache
seit 55 tagen sport und deswegen möchte
ich heute meine chance nutzen und pamela
reif dafür danken dass sie mir den
letzten 55 tagen angetan hat
[Musik]
von 55 tagen habe ich damit angefangen
sport zu machen jeden tag über eine
stunde auf twitter weiß gar nicht mehr
genau warum ich gestartet habe ich glaub
das war so eine spontane oh mein gott
wir sind jetzt in quarantäne lockdown
modus man muss sich doch irgendwie noch
bewegen um mein gott ich habe jetzt
einen twitter-account was mache ich dann
auf twitter ich könnte mal sport machen
und jetzt sind wir so ein richtiger weg
lobte jeden tag sport macht ich habe
wirklich in diesen 55 tagen ob ich
verkatert war überhaupt keinen bock
hatte komplett im arsch müde bot er war
ich habe einfach sport gemacht und ich
weiß nicht woher diese motivation kommt
ich glaube weil ich die leute nicht im
stich lassen möchte
die sich irgendwie darauf verlassen dass
in dem tag sport stattfindet und dann
habe ich immer diese vorstellung dass
jemand sich so vor seinem pc stellt
zudem stream an machen möchte fertig und
seinen sportklamotten seine
wasserflasche in der hand und dann ist
da kein streaming vorstellungen hat mich
sehr traurig dass ich hab ich das
durchgezogen ich bin sehr dankbar dafür
ich habe auch den einen oder anderen
zentimeter an meinem körper verloren
auch wenn das nicht mein ziel war ich
muss aber sagen ich glaube so finden die
zur zeit war ich noch nie in meinem
leben dafür bin ich sehr dankbar leider
hat es eine pandemie gebraucht um mich
an diesem punkt zu bringen was ich ein
bisschen seltsam finde aber darum soll
es nicht gehen es soll heute um pamela
reiss gehen die frau die uns alle
während dieser schweren tage durchgehend
[Musik]
gebracht hat sie hat uns durch gebracht
mit ihren tollen workouts mit ihrer
personelle damit dass sie einfach nicht
schwitzt pamela warum schwitzt du nicht
was ist los mit dir ja und als kleine
celebration wollte ich einfach mal ihre
erdnussbutter cookies machen das ist ein
sehr simples rezept allerdings bin ich
sehr gespannt wie es schmeckt uns vor
allem wenn das rezept von pamela kommt
bedeutet ja dass es relativ okay ist für
einen snack einschüssen ausrede ohne
schlechtes gewissen süßigkeiten zu essen
aber das sind wirklich die simpelsten
cookies die man sich vorstellen kann -
butter sirup mail kokosöl die prise salz
und schoko drop bevor ich noch vergessen
zu sagen ich habe in den 55 tagen nicht
auf meine ernährung geachtet das heißt
ich habe weiter ab und zu mal alkohol
getrunken genascht süßigkeiten chips
pipapo hat mir pizza bestellt burger
gegessen habe halt einfach nur jeden tag
eine stunde sport gemacht
wir brauchen 70 gramm erdnussbutter und
die gehen wir in eine schüssel darauf
kommt 40 gramm ahornsirup und 50 gramm
mehl ich habe mich gerade wie eine
richtig schlau rachegefühlen weil ich
das so aus einem schrank gezogen habe
ensemble yamaoka service points geben
bau neuer maruschka hat mir das gebracht
kleiner fitness live-act zwischendurch
wasser trinken und nach unserem
kokosfett kommt noch salz um drauf dann
alles berühren not gonna live
das riecht ziemlich gut
training wenn ihr das rührt fertig offen
auf 150 grad vorheizen wie wie
schokolade dürfen wir denn rein machen
rät uns schon so viele wie wir wollen
gut die waren jetzt bis 2019 haltbar
aber eigentlich haben wir da noch ein
paar schuhe drops ein paar mehr
pamela
sie haben 50 tage sportschuhe drops
verdienen ok mit unseren gewaschenen
händen können wir die schüssel gehen und
uns ein bisschen was rausholen dann
kommen wir eine kugel daraus haben
unseren ersten cookie also dadurch dass
er jetzt ahornsirup und vollkornmehl
drin das hat man irgendwie das gefühl
dass das gesunde weiß es ja nicht mehr
oder dann so formt jetzt eure kügelchen
zu sein die hinter ich werde gleich in
einem haps auf essen das ich finds mega
gut wie schnell die gehen auch wenn
cookies so gut schmecken es sich die
nicht so gerne weil die sind tatsächlich
einfach nur butter und zucker und auch
wenn die nicht der größte fitness-guru
bin und irgendwie darauf achte bei
cookies habe ich immer das gefühl das
ist wirklich so träsch was man isst das
sind jetzt unsere pamela cookies und die
commerz für zehn minuten in den backofen
sondern auch schon fertig zehn minuten
derzeit kümmern familie reif urlaub
machen
[Musik]
ich nutze jetzt einfach mal die zehn
minuten in denen die cookies im backofen
sind und sag ich was meine lieblings
pamela reiss workouts sind als cardio
workout finde ich dass nachbar
freundlichen note jumping cardio workout
gut dass beginner at work out macht
einfach richtig spaß mittlerweile und
dann glaube ich nummer drei ist auf
jeden fall das zwölf minuten bodyguard
auch ohne squads weil irgendwie habe ich
gemerkt wenn man so squads macht
trainiert es sei meine oberschenkel die
werden richtig stark und meine
oberschenkel haben auch richtig an
zentimetern zugenommen aber ich habe nie
was im hintern gemerkt und bei diesem
zwölf minuten boutique rohware kaut
benutzt man keines kurz und da das spürt
man im hintern ja ansonsten möchte ich
auch einfach mal
danke an dieser stelle sagen ich glaube
es gibt ganz schön viele menschen die
davon profitieren dass sie ihre workouts
teilt natürlich ist es ihr job und sie
bedient damit ihr geld aber sie macht es
richtig gut findet also die workouts
machen spaß wenn man sie täglich macht
habe ich sogar das gefühl dann muss es
nicht so krass anstrengend sein
also man muss nicht jeden tag eine
stunde durchgängig sport machen
ich mache lieber jeden tag so eine halbe
stunde bin ich am ende völlig im arsch
oder hab drei tage muskelkater aber
dieses jeden tag sich eine halbe stunde
dafür zu opfern dass es schon gut gar
unsere cookies sind jetzt aus dem ofen
und ready to während sie im backofen
waren habe ich sie noch mal mit einem
löffel ein bisschen zusammen gedrückt
weil sie einfach nicht auseinander
gegangen sind wie ich das von normalen
cookies kenne und entstehen und jetzt
wieder der allerwichtigsten frage wie
schmecken wie cookies von pamela reif
erst ein bisschen warm also seid so ein
schoko oder gucken wie man der ist nicht
gesund aber schon
ich glaube aber sie hat dinkel oder
mandel mail geschrieben hier
vollkornmehl benutzt mit vollkornmehl
sind die nicht so geil also vollkornmehl
das nicht so geil ich finde egal was mit
vollkornmehl mache es irgendwie nie so
lecker ich glaube ich probiere nach
neuen teig mit mandeln und dinkelmehl
reinmachen jetzt können wir das rezept
ja schon auswendig kann erstmals oder
machen
normales mail zehn gramm mandeln und ein
bisschen vollkornmehl ahornsirup kokosöl
prise salz und das verrühren wir wieder
alles miteinander das ist unser neuer
teig nicht genauso gut dann machen wir
kalifornien schönen mandeln rein und
wieder ordentlich schoko trotz dieser
teig ist jetzt aber weicher
ich kann jetzt nicht mit der hand kneten
nun mach ich mal sowas kandidaten die an
dem projekt kommt die sind so smith ein
riesen cookie machen wir noch die kommen
jetzt wieder bei 150 grad für zehn
minuten backofen während ich hier gerade
auf meine zweite ladung kekse warte
könnte ich ja versuchen euch zu
motivieren dass ihr in meinen live
stream kommt und mit mir sportler also
es macht spaß es ist gar nicht so schwer
man fühlt sich besser an bekommt einen
haken
[Musik]
wir machen das alle gemeinsam auch mit
tritscher nie was am hut hat und
irgendwie komisch findet und denke da
kenne ich mich gar nicht fand einfach
mal dahin wirklich in der video
beschreibung findet ihr den link denn
wir sind gerade auf der rotoren handelt
also 100 tage sport und ich glaube wir
können das sogar schaffen wenn du dabei
bist du fehlst uns noch im team so eine
sekte die ich vergrößern möchte
unsere cookies sind jetzt fertig also
ich finde aber dass sie 15 minuten
backen müssen und nicht zehn sie so ein
bisschen brauner werden sie sind jetzt
die neuen gummis drauf und das sind noch
die mit vollkornmehl und ich muss sagen
optisch sind die vollkommen cookies
irgendwie professionelle aus aber ich
kann mir vorstellen dass die mit der
mischung besser schmecken
20 minuten später ein bisschen besser
ein bisschen knackiger ist ein stabiler
[Musik]
keksdosen wir zusammen auf 55 tage sport
und 55 tage mehr
[Musik]
da ist ein bisschen viel und trocken
deswegen
[Musik]
das konzept kann ich auf jeden fall
empfehlen und wenn ihr weitere
vorschläge habt was ich denn mal in
zukunft kochen sollte oder backen soll
schreibt gerne in die kommentare ich aus
mir dann an und freue mich über jeden
like denn das unterstützt mich sehr doll
und wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal
wieder häufiger auftritt macht mit mir
dort sport das macht wirklich spaß
wirklich es macht spaß
ansonsten würde ich sagen sie müssen
sich mal wieder biss dann heute die
ohren steif und eure schmal wanne